a circle has a circumference of 20 pi it
has an arc length it has an arc length
of 221 over 18 pi what is the central
angle of the arc in degrees so they're
asking for this one so this is the arc
that they're talking about that's 221
over 18 pi long and they want to know
this angle that it subtends this central
angle right over here so we just have to
remind ourselves that the ratio of this
arc length to the entire circumference
let me write that down the ratio of this
arc length which is 221 over 18 pi to
the entire circumference which is 20 pi
is going to be equal to the ratio of
this central angle which we can call
theta the ratio of theta to 360 degrees
if we were to go all the way around the
circle to 360 degrees 360 this will give
us our theta in degrees if we want it in
radians we think we would think of it in
terms of two pi radians around the
circle but it's 360 degrees since we're
in degrees now we just have to simplify
now the easiest thing is just to
multiply both sides times 360 degrees so
let's do that so this is 300 if we
multiply the left-hand side by 360
degrees we get 360 times 221 times pi
over C we have 18 times 20 times 20
times pi times pi and on the right hand
side if we multiply it by 360 we are
just left with theta we are just left
with theta so we really just have to
simplify this now let's see pi divided
by pi is going to be 1 360 divided by 20
well it's going to be the same thing as
36 over 2 which is the same thing as 18
and 18 divided by 18 is 1 so this all
simplifies to 221 degrees theta theta is
2
121 degrees